hey guys I'm Kendra I'm Bonnie stick
around for after the episode because
we're gonna talk about some behind the
scenes of odd man out
see you then continue after me oh we
brought together seven US citizens I am
a US citizen I am a citizen I am a
citizen I am a citizen I am a citizen I
am a citizen I'm a US citizen one is a
liar if the group discovers who the liar
is they'll split a cash prize if the
liar survives he or she wins the entire
prize where were you born
doesn't matter yes where were you born
San Diego thank you don't say this in US
and Canada or ikaw Orange County Orange
County and it doesn't matter what to the
tire started everyone was just like
yelling
he's definitely overcompensating by
starting off the question well how long
have you been in the US what do you
think I thought the first speed round
was awesome it was really cool I think I
kept my composure and stayed mysterious
people often look at me as an
international man of mystery you can't
tell us where you're wrong he looked
right into my eyes and said tell you but
then I'd have to kill you
okay I'm voting you off he was kind of
shady but then he made it too obvious
would they really say that and make
themselves stand out I think he's good
him he had way too much boys your
wall-to-wall spoken-- I thought voting
him out we could just continue the game
he's just too collected he's just too
well put together I thought he was
trying to get himself voted up
I felt pretty sad getting voted off in
the first run but at the same time I
left the stage leaving an unforgettable
impression on these people okay continue
after me I got really nervous especially
because I'm not a singer like I can't
sing for the life of me you know part of
our culture you don't have to be able to
hit the high notes so if she were
naturalized as a citizen she would know
certain things like it would have been
better if we could have just like
approach things a little bit more calmly
and like not like that was born in
America I was born to love you stay with
you like San Diego yeah hold on hold on
before we can make any more assumptions
I think we should get to know each other
first
I'll come you know Hospital have you
learned in NorCal or your life no my
parents got divorced okay so so you went
to different places Jersey Korea yeah
always wait you went Joey yeah I can't
answer everything but we're wasting time
here because he was never any questions
about him living abroad think he brushed
over it a little too quickly and you
okay let start your story yeah so I was
born in Vancouver Canada and then I
moved to the state's when I was 10
Grand Rapids Michigan she's in the clear
so one of your parents can anyone at
them as Americans without tell you have
your dual citizen I got my green card
because my dad got to work these oh yeah
and then naturalized as a citizen the
pleasantries are for later not while
you're trying to win money you know have
any of you guys traveled outside of the
control yes I've been to the Philippines
Philippines okay I've been to London
Canada Mexico and Syria Syria yeah
Ceri i'm syrian oh really yes so how did
you get your citizenship I was born here
in Orange County I visited Syria when I
was like very young I used to come my
grandparents used to live there about 4
minutes 30 seconds you have to narrow it
down
these two are my biggest suspects right
now you do have a Spanish blood in you I
can see yeah I do have Spanish but I'm
not from Spain I'm from Hoboken New
Jersey but I was born in like I said
earlier I was born in Havana he was
pointing everywhere but himself he
became too pushy got to eliminate
candidates right and I see you as
naturalized I see you as maybe born here
I don't know about you a hundred percent
but after him yeah your sus I just
wanted like a peaceful environment that
I could hear what people had to say it
was in the best interest of the other
citizens to keep me around because I was
really here to play the puzzle the
interesting part what does it mean
freedom to say whatever the heck you
want yeah okay I think it's all about
being who you are being what you want to
be because in other countries if you
can't be transgender other countries you
can't even be gay it's the country of
just free expression yeah I don't know I
see it as such a privilege to be able to
link immigrate here when I'm from Canada
which is like okay look I'm not a
refugee I'm not I sometimes I feel a
little guilty of being American because
I came in the right way all of my family
is Mexican and me having the ability to
study here to have a job here it just it
makes such a big difference
I was definitely holding back
information like I didn't tell anyone
that I live in Mexico because I was
scared people would turn on me like you
said it's a big source of guilt because
I look at my cousin's back in Mexico and
they don't have the opportunities that I
have I just got lucky because I got to
be born here I can kind of feel the same
way my my mom actually grew up in the
Philippines their whole life lived in a
very poor family and so she got to move
here because of the freedom and the
opportunity and so she met my dad and I
was able to be born he and I think
that's
so great that she has given me a life of
privilege where she could not what's the
worst thing about America to you white
supremacy I would say that's the worst
had she not answered the question the
way she did I was not gonna vote her out
that's too much of a non US citizen
coming across the border there is hate
there's negativity and obviously we
can't all have empathy and be positive
about everything in the world but I wish
we all were in pathetic of everyone and
everything the worst thing about America
right now is that we have an open border
in the south and we're allowing
everybody to come in and we don't know
who's coming in and that's gonna ruin
your futures not mine but yours
well Muslim are refugees and most of
them are not refugees I'm a refugee I
came over as a refugee there are
refugees who do deeply need help but he
didn't take the side of the unfortunate
and I felt kind of sad to hear that
refugees don't have cell phones don't
have nice clothes and don't come over to
the United States so they can have an
anchor baby you know you guys are
Millennials you don't agree with me and
that's fine the best part about America
we're very inclusive it's not the first
person to tell me that Mexican people
should stop coming into the u.s. or that
Mexican people are a threat to American
freedom people in America think that way
now I just I've become used to it by now
it's the truth especially here in
California when I talk to people that
are of Mexican or Central American and
said you know it's funny when you're in
your country you're white you cross that
border and now all of a sudden you're
Hispanic I believed that she was the
mall because of just that I honestly
voted John out first strategy reasons I
felt so bad because I believed her but I
didn't know who the vote oh and I also
thought I was on the chopping block at
that point I really felt as if everyone
was a US citizen so Karolina was my only
choice where if
[Laughter]
if it's you I'll see you outside
[Music]
he knew the correct things to say before
we went up he was like being so nice and
like how we're in this together like
we're gonna get the mole as soon as I
met them I know that I had to manipulate
then I knew I had to lie to them and I
felt bad I felt so sorry guys so I am a
Filipino citizen I moved to America
three years ago only for college so I'm
here on a student visa I really want to
be a US citizen so I'm hoping for that
one day
for it to be the real deal I can't the
nature of this game to unfairly judge
people being a US citizen can look
differently it can sound different
everybody can be American whether like
your skin tone is lighter darker it's
not related to your culture it's not
really that your language we all have
different opinions we all have different
mindsets not everyone's gonna think like
you are act like you you just have to be
empathetic understanding of why they're
like this I'm just accept it I think I
made an impact and I don't think any of
those people will ever forget about me
guys this is Bonnie she directed the
past couple episodes of odd-man-out
which you watched and I hope you loved
can you tell me like what was the most
profound thing that you learned
directing the series is like kind of
wild because you're constantly
re-evaluating like your own biases
through this process like even just in
like coming up with the episodes
themselves you kind of have to start
thinking about like oh why is this an
episode I've thought of and that's what
you believe is about we're all about
breaking down stereotypes if you're
interested in being an odd man out
episode are casting link is in the
description below also be sure to follow
us on Instagram leave a comment tell us
who you thought the mole was and we'll
see you next time